what  yeah you just uh probably just blundered  the pawn did he maybe maybe it already  wasn't very good but now this was this  is not really necessary um i think vidit  was simply in damn trouble he played  here  now he didn't want to push f5 because  that would make his end game really  disaster and after f5 he gave up a pawn  just like that  take the i mean okay obviously you're  gonna take it  but it's probably not going to be ah  it's not working there's kind of working  because i go all the way to c3 yes yeah  nice trick this is how you say goodbye  very nice very nice by the way um  no it's nothing  it's probably  finished  yeah because there's just there's just  no way to continue um  b5  you just take it d3 you just go here  and you always have bishop c2 right  here yeah you cannot even play there's a  problem you're gonna play  king of three there's gonna be bishop d1  and you have to go here and i just take  this pawn so  yeah that's official aronia has one